it's jerry it was the decade of
prosperity jazz bands bootleggers and
bathtub gin and now you can live it up
just as gatsby would at the legacy club
at circa joining us to tell us more is
ryan clark from the legacy club welcome
thanks for having me i love the gatsby
theme there's just such elegance to it
and that is also showcased in the
cocktails the the legacy club is
absolutely incredible it's up in in in
the circa but tell us about some of the
cocktails you're gonna be serving for
this gatsby night we're gonna do five
different uh 1920s classic cocktails
kind of your probation aristotle ones uh
we're going to make the sidecar today
which uh came out right around 1922. all
right let's uh let's get to it i already
just love the glasses so elegant
talk to us about what's in the sidecar
and i'm gonna i'm gonna make one too i'm
gonna try so we're gonna start with some
of our cheapest ingredients first we're
gonna start with some lemon juice
pre-made and some simple syrup we're
just gonna dump that right in okay those
are two flavors gonna balance each other
out really great which is important in a
cocktail like this uh we're going to get
some orange liqueur where you're using
cointreau so what you're going to do is
pour one whole ounce which is on the
short side of this uh [ __ ] okay and
we're just going to pour that right in
oh you went a little over on that one
yeah well we like our boots
i like it okay
and this is the orange flavored you said
absolutely okay perfect then we're going
to get our cognac which is the key
ingredient we're going to do two ounces
which is the full side of the bigger
side of the [ __ ] okay and we're just
going to pour that all the way to the
top don't cheat yourself on that one oh
you guys never cheat anyone at the
legacy club that's one of my favorite
hangs in las vegas and some of the best
views too yeah it's a good place to go
if people want to go to your gatsby
party how do they get tickets all right
they're going to just check out uh circa
las vegas dot com go to the landing page
that is legacy club and we have an
events tab that you can go on and sign
right up there easy enough okay we got
our we got our cointreau in we've got
our cognac our lemon juice a little bit
of simple syrup we've already got ice in
here we're going to shake it up so all
you have to do is put the big tin on the
small tin oh boy push it down with one
finger
one yeah give it a good press okay we're
going to turn it upside down oh gosh and
this is where the fun part is we're
going to shake it up so one hand on each
tin okay and just start shaking
it's almost like they've done this yeah
you make it look so cool
so i look so awkward but you look
perfect so all we're going to do is be
able to pop that out there we should be
able to
make a little bit of noise that came out
great okay all we're going to do is grab
our hawthorne strainer put that right on
top never knew that that was the name of
that actually right on top of this okay
and we're going to point pour that right
into our glass
okay
and you're doing great it should go
almost all the way to the top i think i
did it right
got all the right stuff in there nice
and then we just have to put a nice
garnish on a little orange peel okay
twist it up and uh put it on the side if
you can or just right in the middle and
we have a great cocktail all right
are you gonna have a drink here i'm
gonna have a cheers okay cheers to you
um again if you want to check out this
incredible event how do you do it
circle las vegas dot com and go to
legacy club
okay that's delicious
yeah i think we're going to have to go
be a part of the gatsby event and i'm
glad you guys brought me an outfit that
i can wear so we got you all set with
that we're gonna we're gonna go check
that out so make sure if you want more
information you can get it on our
website at eightnewsnow.com in las vegas
now we'll be right back
i love it